[Applaudissements]
cette grande pyramide et la nouvelle
machine à voyager dans tant de guy
laliberté
son premier projet à voir le jour depuis
qu'il a vendu le circuit du soleil
comme on me demande a raconté qu est-ce
que c'est qu'on utilise des mots
immersif multimédia
en fait ça m'a juste au début un
glossaire le monde demande et de
l'expliquer la tête vers le sommet de la
pyramide
le spectateur est plongé pendant 60
minutes dans un univers de lumières et
de sons
ce cirque multimédia baptisé au delà des
échos est un rêve éveillé à saveur
écologique on en a une planète on est
dans un petit jardin qui flottent en
premier lieu du cosmos efforts prendre
soin faux pensons et nous tient un peu
solaire cette graine de qu'on veut
planter dans la tête des spectateurs
cette expérience immersive et la vision
de guy laliberté sur le futur du
divertissement énormément de technologie
donc aux plafonds sont cinétique c'est à
dire qu'ils sont capables de descendre
et de monter changer les proportions de
la salle au dessus du public
énormément de laser on a plus d'une
trentaine de laser dans la salle le son
est un vrai tour de force il ya 128
haut-parleurs dans la salle qui sont
partout dans les murs mais également
sous le sol
ce que je peux dire aux gens c'est que
lyon pour véhicules sont nulle part ça
existe nulle part sa planète
alors ça commence à montréal
le co fondateur du cirque du soleil veut
faire le tour du monde avec son
chapiteau en forme de pyramide et il
sait que le pari est risqué
ce total mis en danger ne faisait pas de
bruit moyen sans risque et puis c'est un
entrepreneur dans l'âme mais quand même
une intelligence de réflexion derrière
tout ça parce que je suis en ligne sur
l'île comme toujours sa pyramide le
printemps l'une rouge que le chapiteau
bleu et jaune et au soleil ici
louis fait déprimer radio canada
montréal
[Musique]